-Performing his number-one hit
"First Class"
from his new album
"Come Home, The Kids Miss You"
once again, Jack Harlow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Mm ♪
[Rapping] ♪ I been a ♪
-♪ G ♪
-♪ Throw up the ♪
-♪ L ♪
-♪ Sex in the ♪
-♪ A.M. ♪
-♪ Uh-huh ♪
-♪ O-R-O-U-S, yeah ♪
-♪ And I can put you in ♪
-♪ First class ♪
-♪ Where? ♪
-♪ Up in the sky ♪
-♪ I can put you in ♪
♪ First class, up in the s-- ♪
♪ Up-up in the s-- ♪
-♪ I been a ♪
-♪ G ♪
-♪ Throw up the ♪
-♪ L ♪
-♪ Sex in the ♪
-♪ A.M. ♪
-♪ Uh-huh ♪
-♪ O-R-O-U-S, yeah ♪
-♪ And I can put you in ♪
-♪ First class, up in the sky ♪
-♪ I can put you in ♪
♪ First class, up in the s-- ♪
♪ Up-up in the s-- ♪
♪♪
♪ I can see the whole city
from this balcony ♪
♪ Back in 2019,
I was outside freely ♪
♪ But now they got it out
for me ♪
♪ I don't care what frat that
you was in, you can't alpha me ♪
♪ Keep dreamin' ♪
♪ Pineapple juice, I give her
sweet, sweet, sweet, sweet ♪
♪ I know what they like
so I just keep cheesin' ♪
♪ Hard drive full
of heat seekin' ♪
♪ Tryna come the same day
as Jack? Rethink it ♪
♪ You don't need Givenchy,
you need Jesus ♪
♪ Why do y'all sleep on me?
I need reasons ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I got plaques in the mail,
peak season ♪
♪ Shout out to my UPS workers
makin' sure I receivin' it ♪
♪ You can do it too,
believe in it ♪
-♪ I been a ♪
-♪ G ♪
-♪ Throw up the ♪
-♪ L ♪
-♪ Sex in the ♪
-♪ A.M. ♪
-♪ Uh-huh ♪
-♪ O-R-O-U-S, yeah ♪
-♪ And I can put you in ♪
-♪ First class, up in the sky ♪
-♪ I can put you in ♪
♪ First class, up in the s-- ♪
♪ Up-up in the s-- ♪
-[Echoing] ♪ Are you ready? ♪
-Yes, I am.
♪ They say,
"You a superstar now" ♪
♪ Damn, I guess I am ♪
♪ You might be the man, well,
that's unless I am ♪
♪ Okay, I'll confess I am ♪
♪ Ay, go ahead and get
undressed, I am ♪
♪ Okay, cool, you on Sunset? ♪
-♪ I am ♪
-♪ I'm 'bout to slide, okay,
I'm outside, okay ♪
♪ This lifestyle don't got
many downsides ♪
♪ 'Cept for the lack of time
I get 'round my ♪
♪ Family, makin' sure they never
downsize ♪
♪ I got visions of my mom
sayin', Wait, this house mine? ♪
♪ Can't lie, I'm on Angus,
Cloud 9 ♪
♪ I got 'em on the bandwagon
now, 'bout time ♪
♪ I ain't even got no downtime ♪
♪ Every time I speak, she say,
yeah, that sounds fine ♪ ♪
-♪ 'Cause I been a ♪
-♪ G ♪
-♪ Throw up the ♪
-♪ L ♪
-♪ Sex in the ♪
-♪ A.M. ♪
-♪ Uh-huh ♪
-♪ O-R-O-U-S, yeah ♪
-♪ And I can put you in ♪
-♪ First class, up in the sky ♪
-♪ I can put you in ♪
♪ First class ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]